I think we have time for one more caller
today why don't we go today to the three
zero five area code caller from 305
what's your name and where are you
calling from today I
I'm calling from Miami actually all
right what's on your mind today and
speak up we're having a hard time
hearing you so far okay my name is
Terrence and I'm coming from Miami today
cool um I was just hearing about
Aragon's
um bodyguards from Turkey um who attacks
and protesters yeah the White House
today in the Capitol that's crazy man I
just I'm just surprised that Trump
didn't like talk to anybody like they
didn't he didn't say any like messages
when he was giving a speech to the Coast
Guard it's pretty crazy
yeah we're anything you would like for
the White House would make a statement
you know it's crazy the optics of it is
these guys in suits are just manhandling
protesters in a country where they don't
even have any not that a bodyguard
necessarily has jurisdiction right but
they're just manhandling people in
another country it depicts of it are
insane one guy got kicked in the head
and was in critical condition it's utter
insanity I mean I know yet but like it's
a very a longing like go up against
because you can get into some sort of
diplomatic issues real quick if you
decide to prosecute them yeah like those
bodyguards might have diplomatic
immunity you know mmm
I mean this meta community does that
really go that far reach my
understanding is prized like they just
let a woman like get stomped on the face
like yeah it's cool it's rated up yeah
like make a statement at belief
I appreciate you Friday to our agenda
endlessly crazy all right I think we
were experiencing a bit of a delay
during that last call thanks to
everybody who called in today we will
one day take calls again sorry if you
didn't make it on we had about 15 people
holding throughout the process got to as
many calls as I could we will deal with
some audience questions after the break